Yeah,
I get the same thing where I get people now,
they asked me a question and I give them the answer to exact new,
you're going to say that?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I know.
I'm one of those people,
by the way,
he does that from time to time.
Also,
how you were talking about kind of breaking the loop in your behavior.
Like,
oh,
I want to make a change to that one thing,
you know,
to break the loo and then you start with something small and then it ends up
affecting more things.
And you mentioned sometimes it's hard because you don't get pats on the back for
those little things,
you know?
Yeah.
So small that it's humiliating that you even have to do the,
yeah,
yeah.
But in a lot of time,
like to yourself,
it's like kind of big.
Like I'm like,
Oh,
I'm going to drink eight glasses of water a day now.
You know?
And then it's almost like you're seeking that pat on the back.
Like you want to tell your friend like,
hey,
I drink eight glasses of water now.
And they're just like,
yeah.
So,
yeah,
right.
And you're like,
why do I even party?
You kind of like,
why do I even do it then if no one's gonna care,
you know?
Well you know there,
there's a lesson to be drawn from that too in terms of relationships that's
really useful psychologically is,
and this is a big mistake that people won't make.
It's like if you want to have a good long term relationship with someone,
then you watch them constantly and when they do something that you like,
you let them know even if it's a small thing because they're way more likely to
do it again.
You know?
And so sometimes a personal have kind of an inkling about what they might do
that's good or that would be good for your release,
their relationship with you.
Or that might even just be pleasing to you,
but they won't say anything.
They're like afraid because maybe they won't get attention for it and,
but then they do it and you notice it's like man,
that's super powerful.
Like you have to be really attentive though.
Cause the good things that people do don't stand out the mistakes they make,
stand out and then you say,
well you made a mistake.
Yeah.
But to,
to watch and to reward someone for doing something small.
Right.
That's,
that's a step in the right direction.
That is a killer strategy.
I found that to be true with my daughter.
She's four and a half now,
but oh yeah,
like that.
Some kids really like some kids are tough and they don't respond to punishment
at all.
You just can't.
You can't,
you can't,
you can't intimidate them.
My daughter,
if I just pointed at her,
she would stop.
But my son,
it was like,
that was just rough one.
He just laughed.
He just laughed and run away.
Yeah.
So,
but he responded to reward like mad if I watched him and he did something that
was good and I told him that it was like he was just,
yes.
So Dan is good.
Yeah.
It's reward is harder to use,
but it's more effective if you can manage it.
Yeah.
And then that's not like Kinda how you say,
where you're like,
be careful with the reward when you give like too much for you word for these
small things,
you know?
And then they can't expect.
You can think that that's a problem with the self esteem movement,
you know?
Oh yeah.
Every,
every kid gets a trophy day.
It's snow.
It's like inflating the currency.
If everything is good,
then nothing is good because their house,
there has to be a distinction.
So yeah,
you want to watch and you want to see when the person's made an effort and you
want to see when they've gone beyond the call of duty and then you want to say,
Hey,
I noticed that that was really good.
Yeah.
And the,
and it is scarcity really matters in those situations because otherwise it just
turns into noise.
Yeah.
Patronizing noise even,
which is even worse.
It's like all you're doing well,
doing well.
It's like leave me alone.
You know?
It's such a lie.
Yeah.
I have a fun time with that actually.
I'll put,
like if I have to judge and all through my kids' lives,
if I had to judge them in their friends and I have three daughters and one son,
usually it was the daughters.
I was being some kind of a judge.
I'm going to judge the dance,
I'm going to judge the little play that they put together.
I'm going to judge the,
uh,
acrobatic routine that they're doing in the backyard that always be judging
these things.
And I would have so much fun because I would say they'd do their little
performance there,
one minute performance,
and they'd come out table,
how was it?
And I said,
okay,
first of all,
presentation overall,
I'm giving you a 4.2 I didn't see one smile until you actually got on stage.
That's wrong.
And I would just go through and give them these really shrong critique yards
and,
and they loved it.
They loved it.
That's a tension.
Mad they would be happy to,
and they'd go try it again.
Try the race.
That 4.3 to a 4.5 they'd be smiles like you could see from a mile away.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I just got done.
I was at a,
at a pool party with a bunch of little kids running around and I ended up
judging the diving competition and all the parents were watching and they were
aghast at what I was doing.
Yeah.
That was at my house by the way.
Oh,
I did it there too.
No,
I do it on a regular basis,
but I did it at your house too,
right?
Yeah.
You've seen it in action.
I give the kids a little nicknames and then,
and then I say,
you know,
you were completely unbalanced when you left the board.
It was almost embarrassing for me to watch you go try it again.
I'm giving you a 2.2 yeah,
go try it again and see if he can pump that up a of it.
Yeah.
And the kids get all motivated to go up there and I
2.5 or they're not treated them like someone who could improve.
Right.
So that's a big deal.
That's,
that's better than,
that's better than a pat on the back.
It's like,
because everyone's flawed and everyone needs to improve.
Well,
so when my kids were little,
I taught them how to speak in public.
It took about an hour.
That was it.
So I had them,
they had to read something,
you know?
And so they'd read it and I was across the room and say,
well,
that's not loud enough.
It's like,
I can't hear you.
It's like belt it out.
And then they get a lot of little louder and said,
no,
I that doesn't want to mean read it way louder than you think you should.
And so they did that.
And I said,
well,
that's about right,
because there's nothing more appalling than listening to some speaker that you
can't hear.
It's like,
there's just no excuse for that.
And then like,
make it clearer,
put some passion into it,
you know?
And it was,
it was unbelievable how quickly they would pick that up,
you know?
And,
and,
uh,
that also made me sad because eat,
because it took so little time to get them to do that,
and then they had it,
you know?
And so,
and that,
that like a critic is your best friend if the critic isn't destructive.
Cause it quite a critic does is say,
look you did 10 things and like these five things,
you need some work on those,
they're not good.
And here's some things you could do that would make them better.
And here's two things that you got.
All right and here's three things that you did pretty well at.
And so then,
well what's the message?
The message is,
hey,
you can handle some actual criticism so you're not some little,
you know,
useless,
wimpy thing that's going to die.
Just because someone isn't telling you that you're already wonderful,
plus you're not already what,
not nearly as wonderful as you could get.
So let's keep that in mind.
And then,
you know,
you lay out a pathway for improvement and then you treat the kid with some
respect and,
and you also show that being an adult means that you know more than being a kid.
Cause you,
you know,
the kid does something,
you say,
oh that was really good.
It's like,
what are you saying?
Well as an adult,
I don't know any better than you do.
And that's pretty dismal message because the kid is going to be an adult for a
very long time.
And one of the things we do really badly in our culture is model.
Why being an adult is better than being a child because it is better.
You have freedom and you have responsibility and you have autonomy.
And so we're always so concerned about making our kids feel good about
themselves.
It's like they should be feel good about becoming responsible adults because
they're going to be adults for like 80 years and they're going to be kids for
like 20 years.
So
the adults the goal.
yeah.
That was interesting when you started doing that because the kids are like seven
years old and under.
But anyway.
Yeah.
And he's like letting them have it.
But you youth funny,
you have this kind of tone about you though.
When you talk to kids that it's like,
it's almost like lists that much over theatrical in just that one.
So you can tell he's like playing a character.
Right.
And the kids love it.
It's so funny.
My daughter like loves him.
Um,
and the kids are just scrambling around wanting to do it again and like,
let me do this.
Let me do the,
your daughter's all youth do it.
She's like,
okay,
sure.
So fun.
So plenty kids though,
you know,
big Jocko like ordering these kids.
You kids love attention.
Yeah.
It's their currency and they want attention because adults actually know more
than they do.
And so if you pay careful attention,
like I get along really well with little kids and it's because I pay attention
to them and if they do something good then we had this kid over at our house
once.
This is a sad story,
I told it in my new book.
Um,
so this kid was bout four really cute kid,
really nice looking kid and his nanny had been hurting it car accident.
So he was kinda being shuffled around the neighborhood for,
for daycare for like a week or solely.
And I'd heard some,
not some rumors about this kid and so I was kinda curious.
And so anyways,
he came over to our house.
My,
my,
my wife was also taken care of some other kids at this time.
Um,
and I came home and he was standing,
the other kids were playing in the living room and he was standing in the porch,
sort of in the corner,
you know,
kind of just wandering around back and forth.
And I looked at him and I thought,
that's not so good.
So I kind of poked him a bit,
you know,
and I was poking them and trying to get him to play.
And he had this like really mask of a face on unhappy and I poke him and he kind
of jerk away and all that.
And I couldn't get him to smile.
I couldn't get them to play it.
I thought,
that's not good.
That's not good.
Because he's four,
like he should have,
you know,
acted unhappy for two or three pokes and then kind of laughed and then we would
kind of get into it,
you know,
so,
so that,
that wasn't so good.
So then we had lunch and the rule at our house was eat your damn lunch and say
thank you to the person who made it because otherwise they'll cook you horrible
things and you'll die.
So,
so it's like,
it's hard to cook lunch for.
You have some gratitude,
your little monsters.
And so you ate what was there.
And so his mother,
when she dropped him off said he probably won't eat anything all day,
but that's all right.
And we thought,
well actually no,
that's not all right because he needs to eat and,
and it's,
and it's not all right that he doesn't eat wrong.
And so we'd learned how to feed recalcitrance children by that point.
And so all the kids were at the table and they were eating and my wife had made
some chicken stew and he wasn't eating.
And so she was trying to feed them.
And so we were watching him very carefully and so she bring up the spoon to his
mouth and he'd move his head back and forth,
you know,
to refuse it.
And it was just like about a nine month old would do that a when you're trying
to,
that's their,
their first trick.
And so that's a nine month old trick.
And we thought,
okay,
well something happened when he was nine months old and he never really got
beyond that.
And so,
um,
you know,
my wife was fairly persistent with the spoon and um,
he'd get annoyed,
you know,
squawk bit and she'd put some food in and then he'd swallow it.
And then,
and then as soon as he took a little bit of food and she'd pat him and tell him
that he was being a good kid and she,
man today was not a game.
Like she,
she was really intent on getting this kid to have lunch and so,
so that's fine and he's moving his,
his head back and forth.
But what was cool as she kept patting him on the head and telling me was good
kid.
He was opening his mouth more often,
even though he was still moving his head back and forth.
And so it took about 10 minutes or so,
and she had fed him the whole bowl of chicken stew,
and she said,
she showed him and he said,
look,
you're a good boy.
You ate all of it.
And that horrible mask that he was wearing,
you know,
that massive on happiness.
It just fell off of him.
And he had this great smile.
It was just,
it just made the hair on the back of my neck stand up because you could see that
was the first damn thing that he did being allowed to succeed at,
you know,
and so he was thrilled.